die freie demokratische partei ich
begrüßte dr marco buschmann den ersten
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der
fdp fraktion nicht begrüße ich heran
thome den steffl fraktionsvorsitzenden
und michael theurer ebenfalls der wollen
so fraktionsvorsitzender außerdem
begrüße ich links auf dem bildschirm und
mir professor thorsten kingreen den
bevollmächtigten für diese klage für die
fdp fraktion ja zu beginn ja vielen dank
meine damen meine herren sie haben uns
sehr höfliche mit unseren
parlamentarischen titeln vorgestellt wir
stehen hier oder sitzen vielmehr vor
ihnen allerdings sollte nicht als
parlamentarier sondern mit der
verfassungsbeschwerde nutzen wir ein
instrument das allen bürgerinnen und
bürgern jedermann wie es in der sprache
des rechts noch heiß zur verfügung steht
weil wir uns nicht wegen einer
beeinträchtigung unserer
parlamentsrechte beschwerden sondern es
geht um die verteidigung von
grundrechten von bürgerrechten von
jedermanns rechten in der sprache des
rechts und dafür nutzen wir die
verfassungsbeschwerde es ist deshalb
auch keine maßnahme der fdp fraktion
sondern von 80 bürgerinnen und bürgern
dieses landes die ihre bürgerrechte
verteidigen wollen wir nutzen das
instrument der verfassungsbeschwerde
zugleich stellen wir einen antrag auf
einstweiligen rechtsschutz sogenannten
rechtsschutz
denn uns allen ist ja klar wenn wir eine
entscheidung in der sache in zwei jahren
bekommen dann ist die sache hoffentlich
das ist glaube ich das was alle uns eint
hoffentlich schon vorbei die pandemie
hoffentlich vorbei und wir versprechen
uns natürlich vom ein rechtsschutz eine
sehr schnelle auskunft des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wir sind uns
dessen bewusst ist die hürden dafür sehr
hoch sind trotzdem ist es glaube ich nur
konsequent in der hauptsache ein
verfahren anzustreben aber auch jetzt
ein rechtsschutz zu beantragen
die verfassungsbeschwerde ist
eingereicht das ist in deutschland gar
nicht so einfach
sie muss schriftlich eingelegt werden
das sagt ausdrücklich das gesetz und
deshalb darf man auch ein fax schicken
das haben wir gestern von 15 uhr 59 bis
22 uhr 18 probiert dann haben wir den
versuch abgebrochen und haben keinen
briten aber einen motorisierten boten
losgeschickt er dann heute um 8 uhr 48
den ordnungsgemässen schriftsatz beim
verfassungsgericht eingereicht hat also
die verfassungsbeschwerde diese
ordnungsgemäß eingereicht
ich sag das deshalb weil es so ein
bisschen zeigt was es mit dieser jahr
von einigen gesundheitsämter noch
bevorzugten kommunikationsweise auf sich
hat so lange die dokumente sehr lang
werden wird es mitunter sehr schwierig
verlässlich damit zu kommunizieren in
der sache geht es uns im wesentlichen um
drei punkte meine kollegen stefan thomé
und michael theurer werden gleich
politisch noch näher ausführen herking
green ist berufen auch fragen im detail
rechts technische fragen im detail
besser zu beantworten als jeder andere
aber politisch möchte ich drei punkte in
den mittelpunkt rücken die uns in dieser
verfassungsbeschwerde besonders wichtig
sind
es geht uns einmal um das thema
ausgangssperren die aufgrund einer
nackten inzidenz zahl verhängt werden
ausgangssperren sind ein tiefer
grundrechtseingriff wer seine wohnung
nicht mehr verlassen darf ist im
wahrsten sinne des wortes natürlich ein
stück wald unfrei und die art und weise
wie die debatte geführt ist ob das denn
notwendig sei oder nicht fand ich offen
gestand die politisch
verfassungspolitisch schräg weil ja
nicht der bürger begründen muss warum er
seine freiheit ausübt das ist auch in
einer zunehmend individualisierten
gesellschaft auch absurd es gibt ja
keine standard lebensläufe und die frage
also ich mache das nicht warum willst du
das dann nachts vor die tür gehen
ist die falsche frage sondern die frage
die auch die verfassungen immer stellt
ist hast du staat zwingende gute gründe
um die freiheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger einzuschränken und natürlich ist
die pandemie ein anlass und ein guter
grund die pandemie bekämpfung ist ein
guter grund wenn man aber nicht
nachweisen kann dass eine maßnahme hier
einen sinnvollen beitrag leistet dann
ist die unverhältnismäßig und das können
wir zeigen wir haben eine ganze reihe
von studien auch in dem schriftsatz
verarbeitet auch die studien die die
befürworter der ausgangssperren anführen
wir glauben wir können zeigen dass
dieser nachweis nicht erbracht werden
kann und deshalb halten wir dieses
instrument für unverhältnismäßig
insbesondere in verbindung mit der
nackten incidents orientierung dass also
die inzidenz von 100 und zwar völlig
egal wie sie zustande kommt die ja ein
schwankender wert ist wo man nicht daran
erkennen kann ob es sich um hoch
konzentrierte sogenannte cluster
ausbrüche handelt oder sehr diffuse
flächige maßnahmen
das spiegelt diese zahl nicht wieder
diese kombination nackte inzidenz
orientierungslos ausgangssperre halten
wir für verfassungswidrig und das ist
nicht etwas was wir uns im stillen
kämmerlein ausgedacht haben sondern
diese unterscheidung cluster ausbruch
und diffuse ausbruch ist ein kriterium
das viele gerichte verwaltungsgerichte
oberverwaltungsgerichte immer wieder
angelegt haben und als maßstab genutzt
haben ob eine konkrete maßnahme
verhältnismäßig ist und mit diesem
kriterium sind auch von vielen gerichten
ausgangssperren immer wieder kassiert
und verworfen
mit einem zweiten punkt sagen und der
wird mir auch ein stück weit zu banal
öffentlich diskutiert das sind die
kontakt beschränkungen für geimpfte
person
es wird ja so ein bisschen so getan als
er das ein luxus problem und es ginge
nur um so ein paar annehmlichkeiten und
das halte ich offen gestanden
für absolut schräg ich spreche da auch
aus der persönlichen erfahrung ich habe
bevor ich angefangen habe zu studieren
mal ein jahr in einem altenpflegeheim
gearbeitet als zivildienstleistender und
dort konnte man immer wieder das gleiche
beobachten
ältere menschen die neu in dieser
einrichtung gekommen sind konnten bei
diesen älteren menschen konnte man
leider immer wieder zwei muster erkennen
das schönere muster war diejenigen die
immer mal wieder regelmäßig besuch
bekommen haben die anschluss gefunden
haben auch in der einrichtung zu anderen
bewohnern spricht die kontakte hatten
die an den gemeinschafts veranstaltung
teilgenommen haben
denen ging es gut die blieben auch
geistig rege und fit hatten einen willen
zu leben und deshalb ging es ihnen in
diesen einrichtungen gingen sie in
dieser einrichtung gut und wir haben zum
teil viele jahre dort gelebt und dann
gab es die andere fallgruppe ältere
menschen die in dieser einrichtung
gekommen sind die ein stück weit aus
ihrem sozialen umfeld herausgerissen
worden sind wo die familie nicht
regelmäßig zu besuch kommen konnte was
kein vorwurf ist weil sie vielleicht
viele hundert kilometer weit weg arbeit
gefunden haben gelebt haben und die in
der einrichtung keine anschluss gefunden
haben aus welchen gründen auch immer
weil die chemie stimmte die vereinsamt
sind und dort konnte man sehr schnell
erkennen was dann passierte das eben
auch die die kognitiven fähigkeiten
nachlesen der wille zu leben nachließ
und dass diese menschen leider sehr
schnell dann auch einen noch stärkeren
körperlichen verfall durchlitten haben
dann auch gestorben sind und die frage
ob ältere menschen und die sind ja im
hohen maße geimpft gerade die
bewohnerinnen von
altenpflegeeinrichtungen aber auch
andere ältere menschen die so fit sind
dass sie noch in einer eigenen wohnung
leben
die sind ja im regelfall die geimpften
personen deren soziale kontakte sind
mehr als ein luxus das ist kein luxus
problem sondern es geht darum auch um
ein stück weit körperliche und geistige
gesundheit
es geht auch um die integrität von
familie
es geht auch um die frage darum ob nicht
die fünfte person ja auch bei ihren
kindern und enkelkindern helfen können
warum trennt man großvater und
großmutter wenn sie beide geimpft sind
wenn sie gemeinsam die enkelkinder
besuchen wollen oder vielleicht
gemeinsam mit helfen wollen in der
familie das sind meine ich keine luxus
probleme sondern das sind tiefgreifende
grundrechtseingriffe die etwas mit der
geistigen und körperlichen gesundheit
der betroffenen person zu tun haben aber
eben auch mit der fähigkeit unserer
gesellschaft innerhalb der familie
beispielsweise sich gegenseitig zu
unterstützen und zu helfen und wenn wir
das unterbinden
dann ist es ein sehr tief greifender
grundrechtseingriff und wenn man dann
noch sich die frage stellt was soll das
eigentlich bringen bei geimpften
personen von denen wir wissen nach dem
stand der wissenschaft dass die gefahr
sich selbst zu infizieren oder andere
dabei zu infizieren quasi nicht
vorhanden ist dann finde ich es dass ein
nicht nachzuvollziehender
grundrechtseingriff der ist auch
unverhältnismäßig einen dritten punkt
möchte ich sagen
der betrifft nicht die grundrechte
beziehungsweise er betrifft sie ihn
direkt ist eigentlich eine
staatsorganisationsrecht liche frage
aber auch eine hochpolitische frage die
aber für die verfassungsbeschwerde eine
große rolle spielt und das ist die frage
einstimmung einspruchsgesetz oder
zustimmungsgesetz das klingt sehr
technisch aber natürlich hat der bürger
einen anspruch darauf dass wenn durch
gesetz in seine grundrechte eingegriffen
wird
dass dieses gesetz denn auch
ordnungsgemäß zustande gekommen ist und
deshalb können wir das in der
verfassungsbeschwerde auch angreifen
das ist aber auch ein politisch hoch
relevanter punkt denn eigentlich ist
klar
aus unserer sicht dass dieses gesetz ein
zustimmungsgesetz ist das bedeutet in
dem gesetz gibt es eine regelung die
entschädigungspflichten zulasten der
länder auslöst eine solche regelung ist
zustimmungspflichtig und es ist völlig
klar wenn ein gesetz eine regelung
enthält die zustimmungspflichtig ist
gilt das für das gesamte gesetz aber
warum ist das auch politisch von so
großer bedeutung
ich glaube weil es sich einige
ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsident in diesem land etwas
zu leicht gemacht haben die gehen nehme
ich jetzt durch die gegend oder haben im
bundesrat große kritische reden gehalten
haben dort aber gesagt ja aber wollte
sich um ein einspruchsgesetz handelt
können wir ja in wahrheit gar nichts tun
das finde ich völlig unangemessen
die möglichkeit zu handeln war im
bundesrat da und wenn es sich um ein
zustimmungsgesetz gehandelt hätte dann
hätten enthaltung der landesregierung
und den vielen landesregierung hättest
dazu enthaltung gegeben ich kann ihnen
klar sagen dass jedenfalls die
landesregierung an denen die fdp
beteiligt wäre
bei einem zustimmungsverfahren diesem
gesetz natürlich nicht zugestimmt hätte
nicht zugestimmt hätten und es war ein
verfahrenstrick meiner festen
überzeugung nach um sich dieser frage
nicht stellen zu müssen in diesen
verschiedenen landesregierung in diesen
verschiedenen konstellationen auch herr
bouffier der eine sehr kritische rede im
bundesrat gehalten hat hätte sicher dann
die frage stellen müssen warum stimmen
sie dann zu wenn es ein
zustimmungsgesetz gegeben gewesen weil
es zustimmungsgesetz behandelt worden
wäre
es ist eine hochpolitische frage ist
keine technische frage sondern es war
ein verfahrens trick um diese reden
halten zu können um sich diesen fragen
nicht stellen zu müssen um die sache
einfach schlichtweg durch den bundesrat
zu winken und so geht s nicht
grundsätzlich nicht aber erst recht
nicht auf dem rücken der grundrechte der
bürgerinnen und bürger und das sind drei
zentrale anliegen nicht die einzigen
aber drei zentrale anliegen die wir mit
dieser verfassungsbeschwerde verfolgen
ausgangssperren auf der basis nackter
inzidenz 'nen anzugreifen geimpften
personen ein stück mehr soziales
miteinander zu
wirklichen weil es eben ungefährlich ist
nach dem was wir wissen jedenfalls es
sich um ein minimales risiko handelt
und drittens dass wir diese scheinbar
technische unterscheidungen einspruchs
zustimmungsgesetz in ihrer politischen
bedeutung ausleuchten und aufzeigen dass
das hier ein trick war auf dem rücken
der grundrechte von bürgerinnen und
bürger und für die alle tun wir das wir
tun das als 80 antragsteller für unsere
grundrechte aber vor allen dingen für
die grundrechte von 380 millionen
menschen in diesem land und auch den
über sechs millionen geimpften personen
es werden täglich mehr
um deren grundrechte geht es und die
wollen wir mittels dieses verfahren zu
verteidigen vielen dank herr buschmann
herking in die hand nahm und in den dank
für die einladung
wir würden uns geht eingesetzt dass
ausgerechnet in der hochphase der
pandemie die verfassungsrechtlichen
koordinaten des föderalismus und auch
der gewaltenteilung verschiebt zunächste
föderalismus die erhalten ist für
verfassungswidrig dass der bundesrat
gesetzlich zugestimmt hat daraufhin hat
der muss man ja gerade schon gewesen
wenn nach artikel 104a abs 4 des
grundgesetzes sind bundesgesetzes
zustimmungspflichtig wenn sie die länder
zu gelte leistungen gegenüber dritten
verpflichten und das ist hier der fall
lehnen die länder entscheiden jetzt
nicht mehr wahr schulschließung müssen
aber den dadurch entstandenen
verdienstausfall von erwerbstätigen
entschädigen
zudem wird es auch vertreten dass der
bundesrat der verpflichtung der länder
den schülerinnen und schülern tests
anzubieten hätte zustimmen müssen und
hätten schon da draußen darauf
hingewiesen dass im bundesrat alle
sieben ministerpräsidenten die sich zu
wort gemeldet haben zum teil
fundamentale kritik an dem gesetz geübt
haben es war die rede von einem ich
zitiere tiefpunkt in der föderalen
bundesrepublik deutschland man konnte
sich gerade noch dazu durchringen keinen
einspruch einzulegen zugestellt hat er
jedenfalls niemand
denn das gesetz erweckt den wirklich
fatalen eindruck dass der föderalismus
den wir seit 70 jahren als eckpfeiler
eines residenten verfassungsstaates
ansehen ein störfaktor bei der
bekämpfung der pandemie ist
wir wenden uns gegen eine
verfassungswidrige gewalten verschiebung
bei der anordnung grundlegender freiheit
ausgehalten kontakt beschränkungen
folgen jetzt unmittelbar aus dem gesetz
in seinem anwendungsbereich entfällt der
rechtsschutz vor dem vertrag vor den
fachgerichten der bislang funktioniert
hat verfassungsrechtlich fragwürdig ist
aber vor allem die gewalten
verschiebungen zwischen legislative und
exekutive bei den ausgangs
beschränkungen ausgangs beschränkungen
sind ja eingriffe in die freiheit der
person
und dieses grundrecht der freiheit der
person stützt mit der körperlichen
bewegungsfreiheit eines der ältesten
menschenrechte und eingriffe in die
freiheit der person dürfen nach artikel
104 absatz 1 des grundgesetzes nur ich
zitiere aufgrund eines förderlichen
gesetzes erfolgen also nicht unmittelbar
durch das gesetz selbst darf also eines
gesetzes das nicht die verwaltung im
einzelfall ausgeführt wird die
verwaltung entscheidet hier aber nichts
mehr
das gesetz ist selbst ausführen das
alles ist keine verfassungs dogmatische
wortklauberei sondern formuliert das
anliegen des grundgesetzes
freiheitsbeschränkungen nicht alleine
dem gesetzgeber zugelassen sondern der
exekutive die ein verwaltungsverfahren
durchführen muss um jeden einzelfall
würdigen zu können
das gesetz aber spielt letztlich alles
ein eine abwägung die besonderheiten wie
einem lokal begrenzt das
ausbruchsgeschehen berücksichtigen
könnte eine solche abwägung fällt
komplett aus
und das alles geschieht jetzt noch
aufgrund auf methodisch fragwürdiger
grundlage dann ist ist mittlerweile
anerkannt dass er lange incidents werte
das infektionsgeschehen nicht mehr
angemessen wiedergeben
die länder konnten immerhin noch andere
parameter berücksichtigen das ist jetzt
vorbei
die ausgangs beschränkungen sind malen
wir zudem unverhältnismäßig selbst die
vom gesetzgeber zitierten studien das
sind drei stück
lassen nicht erkennen welchen effekt die
ausgangs beschränkungen haben es wird
immer nur gesagt dass sie zusammen mit
anderen maßnahmen wirken könnten
und auch das ist umstritten denn sie
verbieten ja ausgerechnet den aufenthalt
im freien um führen damit wenn man
andere studien glauben darf zur
verteidigung ausgerechnet in innenräumen
und sie verhindern auch dass etwa
einkaufszeiten und fahrten in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln zerrt wird
der fahrt durch ausgangs beständig um
kurzer er hat nur noch sind zehn stunden
letztlich haben ausgesetzt
beschränkungen einen zweck sie sollen
verstöße gegen kontakt beschränkungen in
innenräumen verhindern man verbietet
also den gemeinsamen abend spaziergang
des alten ehepaars im stillen park um
anderswo eine party zu verhindern
das gelingt in einzelfällen vielleicht
sogar aber die verwaltungsgerichte haben
in den vergangenen wochen immer wieder
und zu recht gesagt dass ein
freiheitlicher staat millionen
rechtstreue menschen einsperren können
um einzelne rechtsverstöße zu verhindern
und vorletzten verhältnismäßig ist es
dass ausgangs und kontakt beschränkung
auch vervollständigte gelten sollten das
gesetz überlässt es dem ermessen der
bundesregierung mit zustimmung von
bundestag und bundesrat eine
rechtsverordnung zu erlassen
die wie es dort heißt zitat
erleichterungen vorsehen kann aber nicht
muss
erleichterung gnadenhalber gewährt durch
die regierung wir haben uns an solche
römischen formulierungen der forschung
wird am 28 mai sollen diese
erleichterungen kommen vielleicht weiß
auch noch nicht in welchem umfang
darüber entscheiden die regierung aber
bis zum 28
mai ist der siebzigsten geburtstag
vorbei in eine gewünschte gern in ihren
beiden töchtern und ihren kleinen enkeln
gefeiert hätte
jeder tag ungerechtfertigte
freiheitsbeschränkung ist ein tag zu
viel
ich fasse zusammen wir haben es hier mit
einem gesetz zu tun dass im duktus einer
polizeiverordnung selbst kleinteilig
sste details über das regelt alles
verboten ist über die freiheit vermisst
die nicht mehr über das normale maß
hinaus gefährlich oder gefährdet sind
verliert dieses gesetz praktisch kein
wort um das macht das verfassungswidrig
vielen dank vieler kinder in petto mehr
vielen dank auch von mir einen guten
morgen ihnen allen ich will versuchen
mit vier gedanken ihnen auch politisch
einzuordnen welche rechtspolitischen
überlegungen uns zu diesem schritt
bewogen haben
da ist im ersten der gedanke des
rechtsstaates rechtsstaatsprinzips wir
sind es gewohnt dass wir alle krisen und
alle gefahren die unsere gesellschaft
und die wirtschaft der stadt bedrohen
mit den mitteln des rechtsstaates
bekämpfen hat kennt keinen
ausnahmezustand in dem zur bekämpfung
von krisen und gefahren
das grundgesetz ausgehebelt worden wäre
wir wir bekämpfen nicht gefahren unter
außerkraftsetzung rechtsstaatliche
regeln und außerkraftsetzung des
grundgesetzes sondern unter anwendung
derselben und das tun wir hier auch ja
dagegen sprach gerade an das dass wir
diese diese maßnahmen mit genauigkeit
eine polizeiverordnung zu bekämpfen
versuchen das infektionsschutz recht ist
eine natur nach polizei- und
ordnungsrecht gefahrenabwehr recht und
wir brauchen immer dann wenn wir
polizeiliche maßnahmen ergreifen wollen
um gefahren abzuwehren
eine person oder ein verhalten die
gefährlich sind für andere die für
andere menschen risiken darstellen
und wir haben mehrfach schon ausgeführt
bekommen von meinen kollegen herrn dr
buschmann von herrn professor kingreen
dass menschen die schon zweimal geimpft
sind jedenfalls so gut wie keine gefahr
mehr für andere darstellen weshalb also
sollte man ihnen ausgangssperren oder
kontakt beschränkungen auferlegen warum
sollten menschen in einem
seniorenwohnheim die mehrfach geimpft
sind zweimal geimpft sind nicht erlauben
wieder gemeinsam die cafeteria zu
besuchen um der vereinsamung entgegen zu
wirken um zu finden dass das alte
menschen in deren seniorenwohnheim
zimmer ihren haushalt da stellt sich
über wochen ja monate eigentlich nur in
diesem zimmer aufhalten dürfen sich nur
den ganzen tag von fernseher aufhalten
können und keinen echten menschen in
kontakt mehr haben und dann vielleicht
auch die lust am weiter leben verlieren
das sind höchst dramatische dinge von
denen wir hier sprechen und deswegen
muss man sich die frage stellen ist ein
bestimmtes verhalten ist eine bestimmte
person eben nicht mehr gefährlich unter
den vorzeichen des fortschreitenden impf
geschehens das ist der erste aspekt der
zweite aspekt den ich ansprechen will
ist er der gewaltenteilung wir haben
nicht nur die regierung die in der krise
das sagen hat die staatsorgane die
verfassungsorgane sind weiterhin intakt
wir knips knips nicht die justiz aus wir
knipsen auch nicht das parlament aus
sondern alle verfassungsorgane des
gewalten teiligen die fassung staates
sind weiterhin funktionsfähig und
deswegen ist es nur richtig und
angemessen dass wir auch diese
vorschriften eine gerichtliche
überprüfung zu führen dass die
proportionen des gewalten teiligen
verfassungsstaates und dieser aspekt ist
auch schon meinen dritter werde von den
proportionen des verfassungsstaates
spreche die rolle des parlamentes wir
befinden uns nach wie vor in einem
ringen der funktionalitäten vor allem
der legislativen und der exklusiven
staatsgewalt und dieses ringen ist auch
noch nicht ganz zu ende
das parlament hat sich viel von seiner
funktion zurück erkämpft es ist wieder
voll im geschehen das war nicht von
anfang an so ein mühsamer weg das
parlament dorthin gegangen ist
aber wir sind wieder jedenfalls
größtenteils als parlament auch mit im
spiel nicht ganz auch in manchen dingen
ist noch die rolle der regierung als
verordnungsgeber mit mit adressiert sie
kennen erkennen dass wir in dem bereich
der impfverordnung der fall der priory
sie
der frage ob es auch dauerhaft notwendig
ist eine im freien feuer oder verordnung
festzulegen
eigentlich ist das eine eine wesentliche
frage und wesentliche fragen müssten
eigentlich so das parlament geklärt
werden nicht durch die regierung sehe
dieses ringen ist noch im gang zwischen
parlament und regierung zwischen
opposition und koalition
und es ist gut dass sich das parlament
sein platz zurückerobert hat denn nur
abgeordnete kennen das land in seiner
ganzen vielfalt seiner ganzen breite von
nord nach süd von ost nach west nach
west wir durchmessen es haben den engen
kontakt mit allen schichten der
gesellschaft und deswegen braucht es
diese rolle des parlamentes nicht weil
wir das ob der notwendigkeit der
pandemie bekämpfung in frage stellen
sondern das wie diskutieren wollen und
das geschieht am besten im parlament
unter vieren letzte aus berlin
ansprechen will ist er der
interdisziplinarität wir hören zur zeit
fast nur auf virologen ohne die geht es
auch nicht wir brauchen die
medizinischen infektiologen
virologischen sachverstand in der
diskussion
aber wir brauchen auch den sachverstand
andere experten das wäre so wie wenn ein
automobil konzern ein neues fahrzeug
entwickelt und da nur die ölkonzerne er
als berater sich ins boot geholt was
denken sie was das für motoren gibt
genauso ist es auch hier
wenn wir die diese die dänische lage
bekämpfen wollen ist es notwendig sich
epidemiologen als berater an bord zu
holen
aber es gibt eben auch andere aspekte es
gibt die wirtschaftlichen die sozialen
die psychosozialen die pädagogischen
aspekte und das ist mindestens genauso
wichtig dass mit mit ins in den blick zu
nehmen denn auch die auslegung auf
vereine mit ihrer ungemein wichtigen
jugendarbeit aspekt wenn wir unterwegs
die vereine verlieren verein nicht
weiter arbeiten können wird in zukunft
ein wichtiger aspekt der jugendarbeit im
land nicht mehr stattfinden oder
staatlich gemacht werden müssen und all
das was vereine nicht bei den
grundschülern leisten können
wenn es ganz schlimm läuft am ende
jugendbetreuer jugendhilfe oder
allerschlimmsten fall sich und
gerichtshilfe auffangen müssen
aber auch wirtschaftliche grenzen stehen
auf dem spiel die existenz von von
familien und dem fortkommen den
bildungschancen von kindern die wissen
dass sie sehr stark abhängig vom
einkommen der eltern
und deswegen ist das alles wichtig nicht
zu sprechen von den schlimmsten fällen
die es gibt
depressionen suizidalität weil die
existenzen von menschen von familien in
gefahr sind all das gilt in den blick zu
nehmen und deswegen ist diese diese
vierfache betrachtungsweise was hat der
rechtsstaat gewaltenteilung war sagt
demokratie was ein auch andere
wissenschaften zu die ja zu dieser party
bekämpfung ungeheuer wichtig und das
sind alles aspekte die wir mit unserer
verfassungsbeschwerde diesem eilantrag
jetzt zur teiles des gerichtes bringen
vielen dank vielen dank
also zunächst mal ist ja der gang nach
karlsruhe
die verfassungsbeschwerde die ultima
ratio
dies ist jetzt heute mit der
verfassungsbeschwerde sehr starkes
signal wenn 80 kolleginnen und kollegen
aus individueller betroffenheit zu
diesem mittel greifen dann ist es ein
starkes signal und da ja auch noch
andere verfassungsbeschwerden jedenfalls
laut medienberichten in karlsruhe
anhängig sind
fühlen wir uns auch bestärkt in unserer
sorge um die grund und freiheitsrechte
in unserem land ich will deshalb
zunächst mal ein einzelnes beispiel aus
dieser verfassungsbeschwerde
herausnehmen
wenn beispielsweise ein kollege mit
seiner ehefrau mit zwei getrennten
wohnsitzen und dem arbeits und dienstort
in berlin hier mit der ausgangssperre
belegt ist führt es zu massiven
einschränkungen im bereich des der
individuellen lebensgestaltung es
reduziert praktisch die möglichkeiten
für dieses ehepaar
freunde zu treffen oder sich zu bewegen
auch gemeinsam zu bewegen etwa nach
langer ortsabwesenheit und rückkunft am
späten abend noch einen gemeinsamen
spaziergang zu machen und dass das ganze
wieder in technologisch einleuchtend und
wirksam ist erkennt man auch daran dass
dann die ehefrau ein klinikärztin
bereits geimpft ist also man merkt dass
hier die maßnahmen die ergriffen wurden
durch massiv in die individuelle
freiheit eingreifen ohne dass die
entsprechende infektor logische
wirksamkeit insbesondere der nächtlichen
ausgangssperre hinreichend auch durch
wissenschaftliche studien belegt werden
konnte im gegenteil bei der beratung im
gesundheitsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages wurden studien herangezogen
das geht ja auch aus der
beschwerdeschrift hervor und professor
konkret hatte angedeutet die genau zum
gegenteiligen ergebnis kommen etwa in
kanada wo ein vergleich von zwei
provinzen in der eine ausgangssperre in
der anderen eine ausgangssperre ergeben
haben dass die reduktion der mobilität
in den nachtstunden sogar zu einer
erhöhung der mobilität am tag führt das
heißt also eine geringere mobilität und
geringere kontakte bei nacht führen zu
erhöhter mobilität und möglicherweise
erhöhten kontakten am tag das kann gar
nicht sinnvoll sein im sinne von
infekten logischer wirksamkeit auch
andere studien wie etwa die studie der
universität gießen die eben keine
wirksamkeit von ausgangssperren
nachweisen konnten werden in dem gesetz
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt also
insofern ist insbesondere diese
ausgangssperre als infektologe unwirksam
und damit der damit verbundenen massiven
grundrechtseingriff auch als
unverhältnismäßig und verfassungswidrig
aus unserer sicht anzusehen ich will
zwei aspekte noch ergänzen
zum einen das thema fokussierung auf die
inzidenz die reine sieben tage incidents
darauf weist ja die bundesregierung in
einer antwort auf eine anfrage
unseres kollegen kubicki selbst hin gibt
eben den schweregrad des pandemie
verlaufs nicht zureichend wieder sie ist
ungeeignet da dafür andere indikatoren
wie zum beispiel die zahl der positiv
getesteten gegenüber der gesamtzahl der
getesteten oder die auslastung der
intensiv mit kapazitäten sind da
wesentlich aussagekräftiger die
bundeskanzlerin selbst hat ja auch die
inzidenz jetzt gestern in frage gestellt
mit ihrer aussage dass wenn die zahl der
geimpften steigt sich die grund
incidence verändere
also das führt zu weiterer verwirrung
und die tatsache dass gestern die
ministerpräsidenten am sogenannten
impfgipfel sich jetzt mit dem thema
geimpfte auseinandergesetzt haben zeigt
ja dass die freien demokraten hier genau
am richtigen punkt ihre warnungen
erhoben haben
im gesetzentwurf sind eben die games
nicht entsprechend berücksichtigt worden
sie haben im reinen gesetzestext sogar
weniger möglichkeiten sich zu bewegen
etwa bei click & collect einzukaufen als
aktuell getestete dabei sagt des robert
koch- institut selbst das von geimpften
ein deutlich geringeres
ansteckungsrisiko und damit eine
gefährdung ausgeht als von aktuell
negativ getesteten also auch hier sieht
man das jedenfalls das gesetz nicht
sauber nicht sorgfältig genug gemacht
worden ist wir sagen auch politisch
bewertet dass die verfassungsministerien
der bundesregierung die justizministerin
lamprecht und der innenminister seehofer
ihre aufgabe als wächter der verfassung
des grundgesetzes nicht nachgekommen
sind das ist ein massives versäumnis
jetzt kommt man hinterher und versucht
nachzubessern aber auch das einigermaßen
planlos nicht überzeugend das was da
jetzt kommuniziert wird mit
nachbesserungen für geimpfte ich meine
an der stelle sagen zu müssen wer
private feiern saufgelage im privaten
bereich verhindern will der sollte am
besten die außengastronomie
sofort öffnen sodass unter aufsicht mit
klaren hygiene konzepten menschen eben
sich auch treffen können das wäre das
beste und das wirksamste mittel anstatt
das praktisch ganz die ganze bevölkerung
in haftung genommen wird für einige
wenige die sich gegen die regeln
verhalten und ein letzter punkt den ich
zwei letzte punkte die ich kurz an
sprechen möchte ist zum einen die
wirtschaftliche lage kollege tom hat es
angedeutet ist dramatisch wir haben im
vergangenen jahr eine million
arbeitsplätze die verloren gegangen sind
nicht nur in hotellerie und gastronomie
auch in anderen branchen
man kann da nur sagen dass die aussagen
von minister altmaier dass kein
arbeitsplatz durch corona verloren gehen
würde jetzt schon lügen gestraft wurden
man kann sagen das ist alles ein kapitel
aus den erzählungen des märchenonkel
peter altmaier ich bin der meinung dass
die kanzlerin jetzt endlich auch die
wirtschaft zur chefsache machen muss und
das entscheidende ist natürlich dem
fortschritt mir sagte ein landrat aus
baden württemberg er brauche von der
bundesregierung nur eines ausreichend
impfstoff alles andere auch kontakt
beschränkungen könne er auch ohne das
infektionsschutzgesetz entsprechend in
gang setzen
bei den impfstoffen ist zwar besserung
in sicht aber es gibt immer noch nicht
ausreichend impfstoffe die impfstoff
kapazitätsengpässe waren absehbar
bereits im mai vor einem jahr habe ich
die bundesregierung auf diesen umstand
hingewiesen im sommer hat staatssekretär
vom bundeswirtschaftsministerium wir
noch schriftlich mitgeteilt es seien
keine zu befürchten engpässe zu erwarten
wir haben erlebt dass es massive
engpässe bei den impfstoffen gegeben hat
und vor dem hintergrund muss die
bundesregierung jetzt alles tun auch
durch marktwirtschaftliche anreize dass
es genug impfstoffe gibt und das gestern
nicht betriebsärzte in die lage versetzt
worden sind sofort impfen zu dürfen ist
aus meiner sicht absolut falsch und
kritikwürdig
denn die 12.000 betriebsärzte in
deutschland können
nach eigenen angaben fünf millionen
menschen im monat impfen das wäre der
richtige weg um in der pandemie
bekämpfung wirklich spürbar voran zu tun
vielen vielen dank wir kommen zu ihren
fragen und erste frage geht an den
decken buschmann
das gesetz ist ja fristet bis juni
selbst wenn es sehr schnell eine
entscheidung in karlsruhe gibt dann wäre
dass er trotzdem hätte das ja trotzdem
nur mehr oder weniger als symbolische
bedeutung weil wohl die ausgangssperre
als auch die aufhebung der
ausgangssperre von kurzer dauer wäre was
ist dann ihre verfassungsbeschwerde mehr
als reine symbolik dass die erste frage
die zweite frage ist wenn sie erfolg
hätten wäre ja die folge eine weitere
kartierung der korona politik und ein
weiterer glaubwürdigkeitsverlust von
politik insgesamt weil das
infektionsschutzgesetz wird ja nur der
ist ja nur deswegen verabschiedet worden
weil die länder nicht in der lage waren
sich auf eine gemeinsame linie zu
verständigen
und sie würden an diesem rad sozusagen
dann noch ein bisschen weiter drehen ist
das mit ihrer verantwortung die sie auch
als parlamentarier haben vereinbar
ja ich danke ihnen für diese kritischen
fragen und ein schuss journalistischer
provokation ist ja auch darin aber das
gibt mir gelegenheit das auch nochmal
klarzustellen also unsere
verfassungsbeschwerde hat große
bedeutung für die betroffenen menschen
professor ken green hat das ja für ihn
angedeutet jeder tag zählt da
insbesondere sagen sie mal vereinsamen
den menschen sie sollen ruhig noch mal
ein paar wochen oder ein paar
monate länger warten ich glaube dass
hier der satz den professor kingreen
gerade gesagt hat dass der gilt es geht
um jeden tag und insbesondere es um
grundrechte geht wenn ihnen grundrechte
rechtswidrig eingegriffen wird dann ist
das argument habt euch doch mal nicht so
es dauert nicht so lange ist kein
argument im freiheitlichen staat sondern
wenn die eingriffe in unsere grundrechte
rechtswidrig wenn sie verfassungswidrig
sind dann sind sie nicht hinzunehmen und
das argument habt euch mal nicht so es
dauert nicht so lange hat keine
bedeutung erstens zweitens unabhängig
davon
er glaube ich dass diese befristung
selber ja auch übrigens eine posse ist
wenn wir der bundeskanzlerin und der
bundesregierung glauben dürften dann
müssten wir ja auch schon vorher beim im
fortschritt so weit sein dass man diese
maßnahmen ich bräuchte deshalb das hat
jetzt nichts mit der
verfassungsbeschwerde
diese befristung ist in sich schon sehr
zweifelhaft ich komme zu anderen frage
nein es geht nicht um kati sierung all
das was an maßnahmen in dem bundes
notbremsen gesetz steht also § 28 b alle
maßnahmen die da drin stehen können die
länder und können wir haben's verein von
michael theurer gehört auch die unteren
ordnungsbehörden die landräte heute
schon ergreifen wir schlagen niemanden
instrumente aus der hand wogegen wir uns
wehren ist dass sie zwingend angewandt
werden müssen auf unsicherer schlechter
unzureichender tatsachengrundlage denn
schauen sie in den paragraphen 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes da werden sie
all diese maßnahmen auch finden was die
bundes notbremse jetzt sagt sie müssen
zwingend unter allen umständen
angewendet werden wenn wir halt diese
inzidenz von 1
und das entmachtet die länder das
entmachtet die unteren ordnungsbehörden
und das führt eben dazu dass ihnen noch
unverhältnismäßiger art und weise
eingegriffen wird und wenn man sich
dagegen wehrt ist das gerade keine
kritisieren sondern ist eine
verteidigung des rechtsstaatsprinzips
und deshalb halten wir das auch für
richtig wir sind um hier keinen zweifel
aufkommen zu lassen sehr dafür dass es
auch um bundeseinheitliche klare regeln
gibt wann welche maßnahmen anzuwenden
sind und wir würden uns sehr darüber
freuen wir haben auch selber eigene
vorschläge dazu gemacht nicht nur wir
als bundestagsfraktion auch
beispielsweise die freien demokraten
einschließlich holstein haben
durchgesetzt dass die landesregierung
schleswig-holstein ja als erste einen
solchen stufenplan auch als
landesregierung präsentiert hat wir
würden uns sehr freuen wenn man sich
dort auf solche einheitlichen regeln
einigen könnte nur sie müssen
verfassungsgemäß sein sie dürfen die
grundrechte nicht verletzen und das ist
eine solche selbstverständlichkeit und
mich offen gestanden ärgert ist dass wir
diese selbstverständlichkeit
entgegengehalten bekommen können wer
sind wir eigentlich und wo sind wir
eigentlich angelangt dass wir den
freiheitlichen rechtsstaat die frage ob
gesetze die die grundrechte achten
müssen und nicht verletzen dürfen ob man
die unter einem vorbehalt stellt wie
lange das dauert
ob dann eine kartierung droht die
sowieso nicht droht und so weiter das
finde ich schon eine verschiebung des
diskurses die mir große sorge macht und
möglicherweise leidet ihr der
freiheitliche rechtsstaat einen schaden
der weit darüber hinaus geht selbst wenn
dieses gesetz aus der welt geschaffen
würde oder aufgehoben würde nicht mehr
gelten würde
wenn das die schleifspur in unserem
gemeinwesen ist dass diejenigen die sich
gegen grundrechtsverletzungen zur wehr
setzen sich dafür rechtfertigen müssen
dann wäre ein schaden entstanden der
vielleicht uns noch lange zu schaffen
machen wird und auch deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir diese
verfassungsbeschwerde einlegen
und uns auch nicht von diesem
politischen argument zurück schrieben
erst hatte sich der teure gemälde ja ich
würde gerne ergänzen
der vorwurf dass wir hierzu unklarheit
beitragen
er wendet sich gegen die regierung
tragenden fraktionen selbst ich habe an
der stelle mit dem kollegen thome und
der kollegin christine aschenberg-dugnus
unseren sieben stufen plan vorgetragen
vorgestellt das war bereits im januar
das heißt es hätte ausreichend zeit
gegeben ein solches gesetz mit
differenzierten kriterien eben
einheitliche standards auf bundesebene
aber lokal regional differenzierte
anwendung im bundestag zu beraten und in
kraft zu setzen
diese anträge der fdp sowohl das
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz von ende
vergangenen jahres 2020 als auch unser
sieben stufen plan wurde von den
mehrheitsfraktionen union und spd im
deutschen bundestag abgelehnt
gleichzeitig wurde der gesetzesentwurf
der jetzt in kürzester zeit durchs
parlament gepeitscht wurde im verfahren
noch verändert einige wenige unsere
kritikpunkte wurden aufgenommen
das zeigte auch wie notwendig eine
intensive parlamentarische beratung ist
und vor dem hintergrund weisen wir also
den vorwurf dass wir hier vor unklarheit
sollten entschieden zurück im gegenteil
die vielen bürgerinnen und bürger die
jetzt in sorge sind wegen
unverhältnismäßiger eingriff in ihre
grund- und freiheitsrechte die sich
jetzt auch an karlsruhe wänden zeigen ja
dass das regierungshandeln alles andere
als akzeptiert ist und alles andere
darstellt als eine grundlage für eine
klare kommunikation und ich möchte daran
erinnern in einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft ist die
mitwirkungsbereitschaft der bürgerinnen
und bürger das entscheidende dass die
menschen freiwillig bereit sind
maßnahmen umzusetzen weil sie ihnen ein
leuchten
dieses sogenannte infektologe
intelligenz die ist bei maßnahmen wie
eine ausgangssperre
aber nicht vorhanden weil ja zum
beispiel gerade die wissenschaftler der
deutschen gesellschaft für
suchtforschung sagen dass das
ansteckungsrisiko im freien deutlich
geringer ist als in innenräumen also
kehren wir endlich in deutschland zu
regelungen zurück die auch für jeden
normalbürger klar ein leuchten sind und
dann auch von den bürgerinnen und bürger
und umgesetzt werden
david zwischen diesen zutreffenden
ausbildung der kollegen doch der
buschmann und teuer
nur noch ganz kurz zwei gedanken
hinzufügen das eine ist die die
geltungsbereich des gesetzes bis zum
30.6
das ist zwar jetzt gesetzes stand aber
am 30 sechster oder siebter wird er die
pandemie nicht zu ende sein
deswegen steht eine mögliche fortgeltung
verlängerung perpetuierung des gesetzes
ja auch im raum
und deswegen ist es schon notwendig
fragen die zwar zunächst ein zunächst
einmal bis zum 30 6 aber möglicherweise
auch darüber hinaus fort gelten werden
jetzt auch eine was uns gerichtliche
prüfung zuzuführen oder zweiter aspekt
ist der vorwurf der atomisierung oder
visierung wie sie es nannten wir greifen
ihr habt keineswegs an dass wir
bundeseinheitliche regelwerke wollen
ganz im gegenteil es ist immer die
fraktion der wir drei angehören gewesen
die genau dies verlangt hat einheitliche
regelwerke von der nordsee bis zu den
alpen und vom rhein bis zur oder nicht
weil wir den journalismus in frage
stellen sondern weil wir sagen wenn es
eine bedienung von nationaler tragweite
ist dann müssen auch die regelwerke
überall die gleichen sein wie greifen
also nicht die bundesrechtliche regelung
als solche an
wir greifen nur die pauschale und
undifferenzierte einführung von
ausgangssperren und kontakt
beschränkungen ohne entweder
betrachtungen der jeweilige situation an
und stellt in frage ob es nicht doch
notwendig gewesen wäre und er bis 704
absatz 4 grundgesetz das ja weil kein
gericht ausführte die zustimmung des
bundesrates der länder nötig gewesen
wäre
dann habe ich eine frage von einem
förster von der deutschen welle zur
frage der gewichtung in ihrer
verfassungsbeschwerde welche der vielen
verstöße gegen die verfassung die sie im
vektoren schutz gesehen liegt aus ihrer
sicht am schwersten
also darf ich das kurz beantworten
einige und rechts verletzung seines
grundrechts vernetzen und wie schwer die
sich aus wer kommt immer auf die
persönliche lebenssituation an deshalb
kann man das so generell nicht sagen
und ich möchte sagen gegen jede
verfassungs verletzung muss man sich
wehren wo man sich kann das ist die
klare auffassung der freien demokraten
als rechtsstaat und verfassung partei
und das ist auch die klare haltung der
beschwerdeführer und wie gesagt die die
betroffenheit die schwere ist in jeder
konkreten lebenssituation stück weit
anders vielleicht findet professor
kinkelin was sagen wo er hingehen können
sich daraus agenten wir haben ich kann
das auch bestätigen in der tat gibt es
dann keine hierarchie sondern wir haben
ja sehr bewusst auch nicht das ganze
gesetz angegriffen sondern einzelne
bestimmungen des gesetzes und damit
wollen wir deutlich machen dass es jetzt
hier sozusagen nicht darum geht an der
eine soziale generalkritik an der
gesamten gesetzgebung zu wahren sondern
wir haben uns bestimmte einzelne norm
aufgegriffen
eine infektion logisch für sinnlos
halten und daher die
grundrechtseingriffe für nicht
gerechtfertigt und deswegen das was wir
angreifen meinte ernst und da gibt es
auch keine lithium verfassungs norden
das wasser sowie durchhalten ist auch
tatsächlich verfassungswidrig
die anlage von rd die bundesregierung
arbeitet jetzt an einer verordnung für
genesene und geimpfte wird ihre
beschwerde damit dann hinfällig
nein denn wir haben ja eine ganze reihe
unterschiedlicher verfassungs
verletzungen die wir mögen also
beispielsweise das falsche
zustandekommen des gesetzes bleibt ja
bestehen das ist diese frage einspruchs
und zustimmungsgesetz das ändert sie hat
dadurch nicht
und zum anderen ist es auch so wir
wissen ja gar nicht was da kommt wenn
wir angreifen dass geimpfte personen
ihre beispielsweise wenn man ein beide
teile sind geben für güter großvater
großmutter ihre kinder nicht treffen
ihre ehre ihre enkelkinder nicht treffen
dürfen und man würde den jetzt erlauben
aber shoppen dürfte gehen aber trotzdem
weiterhin eingehen er nicht treffen
können dann werden wir es weiter geben
dann ist der zustand nach wie vor ein
verfassungswidriger und deshalb muss man
natürlich jetzt erst mal schauen was da
kommen das kommt ein dritter punkt ist
jetzt ein rechtspolitischer man muss
überlegen ob er auch in eine
verfassungsrechtliche qualität über geht
es ist die frage kann man solche für die
verwirklichung der grundrechte
wesentlichen fragen eigentlich in
verordnungswege regeln
denn es gibt eine stehende
rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das ist die so
genannte wesentlichkeit theorie dass
diejenigen dinge die für die
verwirklichung der grundrechte
wesentlich sind im parlament entschieden
werden müssen und nicht einfach auf die
exekutive hier die bundesregierung ab
delegiert werden kann das heißt wir
freuen uns natürlich über jede
erleichterung über jeden faktischen
zugewinn an freiheit dort wo wir es für
sinnvoll halten
den finden wir in der sache gut aber
haben dass die rechtlichen fragen
erledigen sich damit auf gar keinen fall
dennoch wiegen noch eine frage online
von fotos von der faz ein ranking
bewerten sie die entscheidung vom
gestrigen bund länder gipfel über
lockerungen für games der erst ende mai
zu entscheiden hat das ihrer meinung
nach einfluss auf die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes
ja das ist ja eine frage die gerade
schon so ähnlich vom kollegen von der ag
gestellt wurde aber liegt mir natürlich
in der tat auch gelegenheit das nochmals
auszuführen in der tat
welche die wesentlichkeit theorie das
gehört also das gesetz ich habe schon im
gesundheitsausschuss vorgeschlagen dass
wir eine separate erwähnung der im
gesetz brauchen und dort klarstellen
müssen das für immune allerdings prompt
für doppel kämpfte nur noch diejenigen
kontakt beschränkungen gelten können die
unerlässlich sind also etwa die masken
fliegt über die man nachdenken könnte
das haben wir in der
verfassungsbeschwerde auch näher
ausgeführt aber im übrigen geht es eben
nicht dass wir sozusagen darauf warten
müssen dass die regierung vielleicht
etwas vielleicht eine entsprechende
verordnung erlassen wird und das sind
eben immerhin auch noch vier wochen in
und aus diesem grunde sehe ich das eher
skeptisch im übrigen vielleicht auch
noch gerade in den kontext auch noch zur
befristung des gesetzes wir haben in der
pandemie schon einmal erleben das gesagt
wurde na ja das ist ja alles nicht so
schlimm das gesetz ist ja befristet und
bei einer norm im infektionsschutzgesetz
in quadraten fünf die erhebliche
verfassungsrechtliche probleme aufwirft
und irgendwann nach 20 damen werden
still und heimlich doch in schritt also
von daher das was hier passiert oder was
die verfassungsbeschwerde anstrebt ist
sozusagen noch mehr als die jetzt
folgenden acht wochen sondern es gibt
schon eine ganz grundsätzliche frage wie
wir mit freiheit umgehen und mit
grundrechten umgehen
und da sehe ich tatsächlich gerade bei
dieser frage der geimpften
verfassungsrechtliche
selbstverständlichkeiten die ich
jedenfalls in meinen 35 jahren niemals
in frage gestellt hätte die sehe ich es
in frage gestellt und das ist der grund
für diese verfassungsbeschwerde